nous sommes tout à fait d'accord pour
estimer que la danse le cadre d'une
médecine revalorisé nous n'avons aucune
raison de refuser systématiquement à
contrôler et à gros troll paris vers son
il n'y a pas de maladie seulement mais
il y a essentiellement des malades et
donc vous pensez que tout grippe ne
représente pas le même traitement
absolument pas si nous voulons que
chacun puisse recevoir tous les soins
qui lui sont nécessaires ce qui est une
socialisation peut-être nous voulons que
la déshumanisation de la médecine ne
soit pas la conséquence de ceci et vous
pensez que si vous médecin vous étiez
payés par la collectivité au mois
salariés cela entraînerait une
déshumanisation de la médecine
on le constate dans les pays étrangers
de façon évidente
cela ne correspond absolument pas à
l'intérêt profond de chaque malade dans
notre pays bien mais il reste que les
dépenses médicales ne cesse d'augmenter
et en même temps accroissent le déficit
de la sécurité sociale alors il faut
tout de même faire quelque chose de
positif que proposez vous il ya une
chose qui est une évidence il y a de
plus en plus de gens à soigner on les
soigne de mieux en mieux
ça coûte de plus en plus cher il est
impossible qu'il en soit autrement
c'est inéluctable il faut que chaque
malade quand il participe le fasse dans
une certaine mesure comme c'est déjà le
cas par la fiscalisation qui bouchent le
déficit de la sécurité sociale au
prorata de ses ressources
il faut que ceux qui ne peuvent pas
souhaité par la collectivité et ceux qui
peuvent le soit également
née dans une mesure qui n'apparaîtrait
part considérable par rapport à quelque
chose qui pour eux serait dérisoire
est ce que par exemple aujourd'hui les
médecins participent à la gestion des
hôpitaux les médecins ne participe pas à
cette gestion et même dans les caisses
de sécurité sociale
les textes ne les font pas participer à
la gestion de l'assurance maladie
en somme vous demander la participation
nous demandons à participer à la
définition et au moyen d'actions d'une
politique de santé réel